foreign
[Music]
ER Jen Wilson and welcome to this film
independent presents q a for the
National Geographic films documentary
retrograde by Matthew heinemann special
thanks to our lead sponsor the hifa and
our virtual screenings partner Vision
media and now please welcome our guests
today he's the award-winning director of
such films as cartel land City of Ghosts
a private war the first wave and now
retrograde please welcome director
Matthew heinemann
um so we have a lot of members of film
independent that are aspiring filmmakers
so I like to start out with a question
at the top that's about how people
became filmmakers so I'll ask that
question of you how did you become a
filmmaker
yeah
um I stumbled into it I was a uh history
major in college I had no sense I wanted
to be a filmmaker I didn't study film
um didn't have it in my DNA per se
and uh I applied for this program called
Teach for America I thought I wanted to
be a teacher
um I got rejected from such program
and uh and then I sort of didn't know
what I was gonna do with my life and
three friends and I hatched up this idea
to drive around the U.S for three months
um interviewing people from all walks of
life from Mark Zuckerberg to drug
dealers to cancer researchers and it was
a sort of kaleidoscopic Journey to
understand what our generation was about
you know about uh rented an RV and
bought a video camera and raised some
money and
yeah through that process sort of fell
in love with filmmaking
um and taught myself as I went
um learned a ton obviously and and yeah
there's a moment during that trip in New
Orleans three months after Hurricane
Katrina
that I'll never forget where I just you
know was able to capture this extremely
emotional and intimate scene with a a
man seeing his house for the first time
after the hurricane and just felt like
what a privilege
um and responsibility it was to be able
to tell other people's stories and I'll
I always remember that moment as
thinking that this is what I wanted to
do for the rest of my life
what's what's the name of that phone
I don't recommend it in an instant for
say actually you don't even know how it
how it's seen it's called our time
um oh okay is that the name of your
production company now okay
uh so this film
um is about
um the US's withdrawal from Afghanistan
how did you decide that you wanted to
make a film about this
um I mean it really began about I don't
know several years ago with a sort of
cliched question of why are we fighting
Wars how are we fighting Wars
um and as I sort of started to like dig
into that question
um begin conversations with different
elements of the uh US military
eventually got connected with my
producing partner Caitlin Caitlin
McNally
who had vast uh connections with the
Green Beret Community
um and so you know the original sort of
intent I guess to some degree was this
holistic portrait of what a deployment
was
um looking at it both from The Soldier's
perspective but also the family at home
and and that's what we started out doing
it took years to get access to to do
this in bed
um covet happened by the time we
actually went to deploy
um you know it became clear that
actually maybe we can tell this
different story the story of the
the longest warning was history through
the prism of this uh deployment
um and it turned out to be in fact the
the last U.S deployment to Afghanistan
that yeah that was gonna be my next
question is how difficult is it to be
able to get permission to film something
like this it sounds like it's
tremendously hard
um
uh so you were there
shooting when when everybody found out
that the US was going to be withdrawing
and
um online it says they found out in
April 2021 that they had to be all out
by September
was was that was the case
um
no I mean
depended on exactly who you were and
where you were but for the most part you
know the true true with thrall happened
quite quickly after that announcement uh
and the Green Berets
um they needed to do what was you know
what I learned uh and obviously the
title of the film was uh you know 10-day
retrograde
um retrograde is a military term for
leaving a war zone
um different units different places left
at a different time period and with
different lengths of that retrograde but
the the team that we were with
um you know it was quite short
and and then obviously fast forward to
when the Afghan Army lost to the Taliban
and that you know human Saga played out
at the airport
um President Biden sent in troops back
to Afghanistan to help with evacuation
efforts
um
in a sort of ironic and tragic twist of
fate
so yeah the the green brace they seem
um in that footage to be pretty dismayed
about what's going on
and
upset
did they
I mean I was I'm assuming they all felt
like they did not get to finish the work
that that they started there and they
were sad to leave
the Afghanistan in that state is that
correct
in
yeah I mean I think the you know the
There's real Motif in the film of
holding on faces for a really long time
you know faces don't lie and
um
in these very intense environments you
know you don't and in my style of
filmmaking I don't really you know I do
interviews and
um
it's you know it's an observational
style of filmmaking and
the you know their faces spoke more than
any interview or words could ever say
you know and I think it was
there's a number of things there's a
sense of
obviously dismay that they're leaving uh
and and
um
I guess you know trepidation of of
leaving their Partners behind I mean in
many of these guys that worked for some
cases in decades some cases years some
kids and months but
um with their Afghan counterparts and so
they they knew that they were you know
leaving them
behind that they were leaving them in a
really really tough spot the Afghan Army
relied on this partnership with the
American Military
um and so they knew that by leaving
their their handicapping them in a major
way
um and you know you could you could feel
that in the room you could see that on
their faces and obviously in the Afghan
side the trepidation of you know what's
to come
um knowing that this could potentially
lead to you know extreme danger for them
and their families and the loss of their
country
um
and you know it all just read it right
on in in on their faces in that moment
I felt really bad for everybody because
it seemed
it felt like that at a certain point
people I guess in our government decided
that
the situation in Afghanistan didn't work
wasn't working and the only choice left
was to pull out but
the soldiers weren't Partners in the
information sharing on that and the
people of Afghanistan weren't definitely
the Afghanistan's Army weren't
didn't get information on that either
uh I know it's a huge question
but I'm wondering
um if you have any idea what what was
behind the decision making on on leaving
did was it basically just
a situation like Vietnam where we just
said we didn't win this war and we're
pulling out
I'm happy to answer the question I I I
didn't I didn't make this movie as an
attempt to understand you know how we
got here what went wrong who's at fault
who to blame
you know I get criticized all the time
with my films for not giving context
um you know I it's my belief that you
know context is a slippery slope and the
more context you give the more context
audiences want a need and and that to me
takes away from the visceral experience
of being in those rooms in those places
and and emotionally connecting with your
character with your subjects with the
situation that they're living in
um you know my goal with these films is
to take these large amorphous subjects
and to humanize them to try to put a
human face to them
um there's enough certainly enough news
media polarized news media divisive news
media pontificating on the reasons why
all these things happened
um I don't feel like that's my job
um I feel like my job is to tell a story
um a deeply personal story and to get
you to care a little bit more to have
you a little give you a little bit you
know have a little bit more empathy
um
for these conflicts that feel so distant
but really aren't
um sorry for the long preamble to your
question but I mean the short answer is
is that
this is me speaking as a human being not
as a filmmaker you know in what's not in
the film is is these conversations
started with Trump
you know the Doha Accords which began
the peace process with the Taliban began
with Trump and there was two parties at
the table it was the Taliban and it was
the U.S US government
the one major stakeholder that wasn't at
the table was the Afghan government in
the Afghan Army and so the beginning of
the unraveling of all this began with
those Accords
um so the title of this film retrograde
it refers to the what they called the
mission of pulling out of the country
right
but the word retrograde also means
moving backward
um just
um curious if that's part of did you
mean a double The Double entender with
it with the title
um
yeah of course I mean
yeah I mean we are we are backed
we're back to where we were 20 years ago
and what have we done what have we
accomplished
um thousands of lives lost trillions of
dollars
um and
you know girls can't go to school women
can't walk out with that their face is
covered the economy is in free fall
foreign aid has shrunken
um it's as bad if not worse than where
we were 20 years ago
um you know and the whole reason for
going into the country in the first
place was because it was under the
auspices of you know the the Taliban is
harboring International terrorists uh
after 9 11.
you know just a couple months ago the
head of Al Qaeda was was found and
killed in the center of Kabul
um so it's it's it's really sad
um and I hope among other things that
this film you know when's the last time
you had a conversation on Afghanistan
the international news media media has
been usurped by Ukraine
um you know rightly so it's very very
important story but I hope among other
things that this film reinvigorates
conversation on Afghanistan
um you know the longest warning it was
history in this country and these people
that we left behind
so after you spend the time with the
Green Berets then you're with General
Sammy Sadat right
um
was it the same situation getting
permission to shoot with him where it
was like really difficult to gain
his trust in you
it wasn't all it you know didn't have
all the bureaucracy that that the U.S
had
um it was a matter of predominantly
gaining his Trust
uh to embed with him and his men
which happened relatively quickly as
definitely compared to the U.S side of
things
um and then we you know we went back and
embedded with him
you know over the course of the next
several months and not and obviously the
the whole completely you know the lens
of the film shifted dramatically
um and he became you know emerged really
as his protagonist
uh in the film
how big of a crew did you take with you
um and I I guess it seems like a crazy
question to ask but I assume that that
you all were in quite a bit of danger
shooting this film
uh yeah I mean I like to have a really
small footprint
um it's often just one person shooting
or you know maybe two
um I shoot myself I have two other
incredibly talented cinematographers Tim
grushka and Olivia sarbell with me as
well
um and again you know sometimes it's
just one of us shooting other times
there's two of us cross shooting
um but
you know the the goal in making really
intimate character driven films like
this is It's become part of the fabric
of the daily lives of our of our
subjects and and that's
you know sometimes that trust is built
immediately sometimes the trust takes
weeks or months
um obviously we we gain the trust of
General Sadat but you know there's a lot
of people around me around him so you
know making everyone else comfortable
with with our cameras
um at what really amounts to be the most
difficult moment in their lives
um
was tough and you know obviously as you
acknowledge like you know yes of course
we found ourselves in very dangerous and
difficult situations numerous times uh
countless times
um and making this film
from from the sort of obvious moments
like you know that was me filming in the
Blackhawk helicopter as we were getting
shot at by the Taliban as they're
shooting Rockets
um at the helicopter and you know in
those moments
you have zero agency like I don't know
how to fight helicopter I don't know how
to shoot a gun
um
all I can do is focus on the craft of
filmmaking on on my camera you know I
can't you know
control anything else so I choose to
focus on focusing on my exposure on
aperture on making sure the record
buttons on
um and that sort of calmed me down on
these very intense situations
um you know there's obvious moments like
that in the film then there's more you
know banal moments in the film like
yeah I mean there's there's a scene
obviously where
we narrowly miss a suicide attack to his
Convoy that you know I was driving in
with him
um but you know every other car ride
had this tension of knowing that the
Taliban were trying to take him out that
that they were sending suicide bombers
towards him or trying to at least every
single day so even just driving the car
was scary
um even though you might not feel that
within every frame uh while driving
the scene towards the end of the movie
of course you start with it and then you
end with it at the Kabul airports with
all the people scrambling to to try to
get on planes and get out of the country
uh it's heartbreaking we saw
bits and pieces of it on you know the
national news in the United States
um but I feel like you are footage was a
lot different than that and that it
wasn't you know like sound bites it was
like long longer takes and
can you talk about shooting that
sometimes it seemed like you were in the
midst of the crowd itself that was like
surging towards the the Army and the
planes
yeah I'll try to keep the story I mean
so there's a four hour answer that
question
okay two minute answer I'll try to do
the two minute basically mid-august
we were
um
hoping sorry for the New York uh score
behind us of the sirens
um
in mid-august we
basically you know we're hoping to go
back and film The General sadata pundits
were saying the Afghan Army can maybe
hold on for two three months at the most
six months
um then eventually fall into the Taliban
very unclear by the time we got to Dubai
to fly into Afghanistan things were
starting to fall quite rapidly
and when we went to the lands in Kabul
in the valley of Kabul
the pilot got an intercontinent said you
know we can't land the plane on the
tarmac we were so low that all of our
phones started to ping ping ping ping
ping and we got all these news alerts at
the Taliban had taken over Kabul that
the plane on the tarmac was president
ghani the president of Afghanistan
fleeing
and the pilot was too scared to land we
went back to Dubai
and I just felt like it was the greatest
failure in my entire career we had spent
eight months building to this moment to
this tragic tragic day historic day
and our main
subject General Sadat was at the center
of it and I'm sitting there in a hotel
100 miles away missing it all
and just somewhat self-loathing of if
you know the what if what if we got on a
plane earlier what if you know fill in
the blank
and basically spend every single waking
hour trying to figure out how to get
back into Afghanistan
um
which we did several days later but by
that time General Sadat had been forced
to flee
and with every you know door that closes
the door opens with every every failure
comes an opportunity and the opportunity
that this gave us was
you know as we sort of pondered
at this point it was Tim and I shooting
you know what is the story we're telling
and it allowed us to open up the
aperture to show the civilians that
the green rays were fighting for that
General start was fighting for the
civilians that so often in these
discussions of Wars get lost
um
you know
big policy decisions are often made by
white men and white houses far away but
they impact families Sons daughters
mothers sisters and
it was important to humanize that and I
don't think the film would be what it
would be if we didn't have that side of
the quote-unquote story
um and so when we landed we made this
decision to leave the wire to leave the
airport and go out into the city to see
what you know Taliban rule felt like
um one of the first things we filmed was
that Taliban meeting
um which was obviously quite surreal
being on that stage uh
you know sneaking into that meeting be
on that stage after having spent most of
my conscience just adult life hearing
about the Taliban previous several
months being shot at by the Taliban
um and to be on that stage with them and
then we started to go around to the
different gates to film you know from a
civilian perspective you know this
desperate plea to flee
um you know the impending Taliban
takeover
and yeah I mean it was it was
just some of the toughest situations
I've ever found myself in my career that
you know the scene that you mentioned in
the question of
when you know a sea of people or or
thousands of people are pushing up
against the cement wall trying to get
through you know I made a decision to
make my way through that crowd and get
to the front of it and truly I mean
probably probably one of the scary
moments of my career there's a really
really high likelihood of a stampede
um there's tons of little kids around
and just felt like
you know this the crowd was swaying as
people pushed and push and pushed and
you know it's rare that I entered
intervene in situations like that you
know I really feel like it's my job to
capture these moments but you know I I
count you know numerous times about
myself putting the camera down and just
begging people to relax and calm down
and explaining to them that look that
door is not opening
that they're not going to let more
people in
um and that they ever needs to relax or
people are going to die
um you know they hadn't a lot of them
hadn't had a food or water for for days
begging the Marines up on the wall to to
hand them water
um so it was really difficult I mean the
scene at the Abbey gate sorry this is a
long answer to your question but
um the scene of the Abbey gate
it was unlike anything I'd ever seen of
thousands of civilians packed like
sardines in a four foot sewage ditch
as 18 year old Marines who weren't even
alive when the Twin Towers fell were
making these impossible Sophie's Choice
decisions that's a sewage ditch I had no
idea when I was watching that they're
all standing in a sewage Stitch oh my
God yeah I mean the the tragic metaphor
obviously isn't lost there and you know
as these 18 Marines are making these
Sophie's Choice decisions on who to let
in who not to let in as the Taliban is
watching at gunpoint as Isis is circling
around
um in suicide best waiting to attack
which happened 12 hours later in that
very spot
it it was only anything I'd ever
witnessed and I just had tears streaming
down my face continually having to wipe
down the lens and all I could think
about was you know what have we done
um
does being in that situation does does
it feel like it
it makes you feel like you don't want to
put yourself in in that position of
making films like that anymore or is it
the opposite where you feel like you
really have a responsibility to show
everything that you can
um
or maybe both yeah it's at the moment
it's probably like what the hell am I
doing here
no I mean it's a you know there's a
there's a sort of PR answer that
question and there's a personal answer
to the question I
look I mean these films have taken a lot
out of me there's no question about that
um
I
I suffer you know from PTSD I have
nightmares often
um
you know the last two years have been
pretty heavy between making the first
wave of film about the first four months
of covid in New York or where I was
embedded in ICU and queens to this to
you know all the other films I've made
it's been heavy you know I've seen a lot
of death and it's
um
you know that's that's one side of
things and then the other side of things
is I'm extremely privileged you know I
have a blue passport that allows me to
come home that allows me to sit in my
office here in New York and talk to you
um and
you know with that privilege comes
responsibility and so I do feel a
responsibility to continue to make films
like this to tell stories that
um
you know I think are important to tell
and you know as documentary filmmakers I
feel like we're filling a void
in
in the sort of media landscape if you
will uh where you know as news budgets
are shrinking as foreign bureaus are
shrinking you know we have this also
privilege of of living with a story for
months if not years both in shooting and
editing
um and I guess on one basic level
retrograde is a historical document
of this moment in time and you know
hopefully something we can learn from
because
retrograding a war zone leaving a war
zone is something that has happened
throughout history and will continue to
happen as we fight Wars and what can we
learn from it
um so I'm just wondering what what's the
status of Sammy Sadat now uh at the end
of the movie he's in the UK is that
where he still is no
um he's still an exile he's not in
Afghanistan
um
and yeah I think it's he's having it's
it's it's tough it's tough
um
I guess that's probably an
understatement I mean it's he's having a
really tough time obviously and not only
did he
you know lose the war
um he's a refugee
um in another country
um and obviously all the
trauma of of of
what he and his men went through in
those final days and final weeks and
fighting
um so I think he's processing a lot
right now
um so my last question was going to be
what's next for you which is you know
interesting we're talking about you know
the we're just talking now about the
aftermath for you making your films
um but are you working on something else
um currently
yes I'm I'm editing a film I've shot for
the past several months about uh the
musician John Batiste uh and his wife
sheilaika
um
totally different type of film
um but something I'm really excited
about too so that sounds great this is
the first time you've made a music
subject film
um I did something a couple years ago on
uh J Balvin I called the boy from
Medellin
um so I've I've sort of
yeah done it once before but this is uh
is music one of your passions
I yeah I think for sure I mean I I
wouldn't even necessarily say this John
Phil I mean it is he's a musician and
there's a lot of music in the film but
it's I think it's a lot more than that I
hope
um
so
yeah
um so when does retrograde come out is
it this Friday
um in La it opens in theaters this
Friday yeah
okay it opened this past weekend in New
York and it's opening
um
uh in L.A and and expanding across the
country uh this coming weekend
well I want to say thank you so much for
coming to talk with us about this film
also thank you for making it
um
it's it's a film that made me want to do
a lot more reading and
discovery of things that
I haven't been paying attention to
um which I think is great I always think
that's positive if I see a film and then
I want to explore that subject so
that feels like a success and I feel
like a lot of people will feel that way
about the film as well
and it's a tough subject and I
appreciate you
continuing to tackle
um
things like this that don't have any
clear answers you know
well I I really appreciate it and
yeah I think
what you just said is is definitely one
of the goals of what I do is you know I
think
I like presenting stories without clear
answers or or clear takeaways maybe
that's the reality of life
um and especially something as complex
as the war in Afghanistan
um
at the very least I hope people walk
away you know carrying a little bit more
with a tiny bit more empathy and
curiosity of of you know what what
happened there and what continues to
happen there and
um so thank you for for saying that
sure well thanks so much for coming
today and um good luck to you
um on this film
and on future films
[Music]